thank you very much it is now 5 33 so
colder temperatures as sherry mentioned
outside a lot of us are left with some
pretty expensive heating bills yeah it
keeps going up every year there are a
number of assistant programs though out
there for families who have to make some
very tough decisions when it comes time
to pay those bills hector maher joining
us live this morning hector you have a
list of some resources for folks
we do and you know some families right
now are having to make that tough
decision about whether to pay their
bills or buying groceries and we have a
program here this is offered by envy
energy this is for those 62 or older
this is called project reach for example
if you're wondering whether you qualify
or not
for this the requirement is for a
household size between one or two people
for it to be
underneath twenty four thousand
seven hundred and that's just one option
though we also talked about uh nevada
two one one
nevada211.org offers a range of services
if you go through a simple clicks on
their website it walks you through
holiday donations housing cares housing
assistance programs and help with
utilities hope link of southern nevada
says many families are still recovering
financially from the pandemic and
they're seeing this right now go up the
cost of winter utility bills is not
making things easier
they're working families but they're
just not making it and so shortages come
up in certain places
we have a real strong heart for senior
citizens though who are on low income
and fixed income
who are having to make decisions do i
pay a utility bill or do i eat a second
meal today
that was don miller with hope link who
says those are real life decisions
happening here in our valley the
organization says covid related
government grants are still available
and they can help you apply for those
the best thing to do is to give them a
call or browse through their website so
again even if you don't qualify for some
of those programs all you have to do is
give the utility company a phone call
oftentimes they're willing to work with
you and put you on a payment plan
instead of just cutting your electricity
reporting live hector mejia live local
now